" Bonsoir à tous, à la une de l’actualité,
le mariage pour tous.
Les députés vont attaquer
une nouvelle séance de nuit à l’Assemblée. "
C’est un débat
qui passionne la France.
On en parle dans les déjeuners
de famille le dimanche matin
dans les dîners en ville
si je puis dire
il y a des manifestations
dans la rue
des gens sont venus prier
devant l’Assemblée nationale
à genoux devant
l’Assemblée nationale.
C’est des débats qui vont avoir lieu
le jour, la nuit, les week-ends
donc il faut être là
en permanence.
" Nous serons simplement plus
nombreux pour chanter Le temps des cerises
et gais rossignols
et merles moqueurs
qui seront tous en fête et nul
n’aura peur des chagrins d’amour. "
À la fin de la première lecture,
il est 5h40 du matin
un samedi matin,
vous imaginez!
Ils étaient donc en séance
depuis la veille
c’est incroyable,
des débats marathons!
" Une nouvelle fois, les débats se sont
tournés vers la gestation pour autrui
plus que sur
le mariage pour tous.
- Vous êtes en train
de créer un précédent,
vous êtes en train
d’assassiner des enfants!
- La majorité de demain remettra
l’ouvrage sur le métier
que vous le vouliez ou non! "
Nous on avait la force de frappe de 24,
25 journalistes de la chaîne
qui se consacraient
uniquement à ça.
Il n'y a aucun média, aucune chaîne
qui pouvait faire ça!
" - Referendum! Referendum!
- Non mais regardez le spectacle
que vous êtes en train de donner!
Je vais lever la séance,
je vous préviens… "
Des fois, c’était des clashs,
mais il se passait véritablement des choses!
" - Ne prenez pas la lourde
et grave responsabilité
de violer des millions
de consciences.
- Aucune différence ne peut servir
de prétexte à des discriminations d’État. "
On a fait des belles audiences,
ça a très bien marché.
On a été beaucoup repris
sur les autres chaînes donc oui,
on avait vraiment le sentiment
que là il fallait qu’on soit à la hauteur.
Malheureusement, c’est pas
tous les jours qu’on avait comme ça une loi
qui faisait autant débat dans la société
et que donc il fallait bien le traiter.
" L’Assemblée nationale
a adopté le projet de loi
ouvrant le mariage aux couples
de personnes de même sexe! "
Et donc voilà,
on a eu le sentiment,
on a senti, si je puis dire,
un peu le vent de l’Histoire.
On s’est dit, voilà, de toute façon,
qu’on soit pour ou qu’on soit contre
c’est un moment important
dans l’évolution de la société française.